je vais vous parler aujourd'hui de ça ça
est ce que ça vous parle ça ce sont des
rendus très probable des futurs huawei
p30 pétron parce que oui les paie 30 et
rétro c'est dur à dire parce que j'en
fais un post louis l'épée 30 et petre en
prô ne vont pas tarder ils seront
présentés le 26 mars prochain à paris
d'ailleurs j'y serai le 26 mars prochain
à paris je vous réserve des surprises
vous invite donc à vous abonner dès
aujourd'hui pour tout savoir alors cp 30
et p 30 pro c'est dur à dire à peu près
30 procès jusqu'au show jeu fourche
malang bref oublions ils vont être juste
énorme il va y avoir plein de chose de
dingue dessus l'année dernière oui y'a
vraiment monté d'un cran au niveau de la
sortie dp 20 et p20 procès plus facile a
dit faire que p 30 et ils ont confirmé
avec le met vin et le mail vaincrons
donc là on attend non pas des
smartphones complètement hallucinant
mais des smartphones qui vont continuer
à emmener huawei encore plus haut à
finir de continuer ce virage qui était
amorcée en 2010 huitième mon avis 2019
waouh il va faire très très mal avec ses
nouveaux smartphones ce que je vous
propose tout de suite c'est de regarder
la fiche technique voir à quoi ils vont
sembler mais surtout ce qui est pour
nous apporter vous allez voir ça envoie
du bois
[Musique]
vous le savez dans les usages des
smartphones il ya aujourd'hui deux
points essentiels le premier c'est le
côté multimédia d'avoir un grand écran
un bel écran sur lequel on peut
visionner des vidéos les sur les réseaux
sociaux
ce que vous faites habituellement ça je
vais pas vous l'apprendre mais
d'ailleurs deuxième point je pense pas
vous l'apprendre non plus c'est le côté
photo vidéo surtout photo parce que on
prend en photo beaucoup de choses on
immortalise beaucoup de choses et on
aime beaucoup partagé notre quotidien
avec nos amis ou même avec de tierces
personnes sur les réseaux sociaux et
c'est justement là où aurélie dernière a
mis le doigt directement dessus était
beaucoup plus loin avec un smartphone
qui a changé la donne
réinventer c'est un peu dur peut-être
pour les autres mais en tout cas ils ont
fait vraiment très très fort en termes
de propositions photos surtout photo je
dirais un peu vidéo mais surtout photo
c'est vraiment là dessus que le point
d'orgue a été mis à cette année vont
continuer devons aller encore plus loin
vous allez voir c'est vraiment vraiment
génial or vous avez deux modèles qui
vont arriver p30 ep 30 pro ce modèle là
avec les côtés légèrement incurvé
incurvé pardon c'est ça devrait être le
paie 30 que vous retrouverez également
ici alors qu'est ce qu'on voit qui est
super intéressant le p 30 promouvoir
l'écran incurvé le paie 30 noms une
petite encoche goutte d'eau qu'on va
retrouver sur laon et sur l'autre modèle
et surtout vous le voyez à l'arrière sur
le paie 30 pro on va trois modules
photos ici trois ici mais vous avez un
quatrième qui sera positionnée
normalement juste sous le flash
je vais vous expliquer à quoi ça
correspond et surtout il ya tout qui
devrait vraiment être génial sur ses
smartphones c'est le fait qu' il devrait
être tout là en dessous et au dessus
pour pouvoir le poser à la verticale
pour faire des photos c'est que rendu
qui ont été publiés sur internet alors
on sait pas ça va être réellement c'est
en tout cas la proposition est vraiment
très très très mal et parce que je veux
smartphones en règle général dahi 100
pas forcément debout se voulait poser
ils ont cependant plutôt à tomber donc
on prend des trépieds je n'ai pas un ici
pour les stabiliser tandis que la
commande aller beaucoup plus long terme
de photos on pourrait le poser comme ça
et photographié très facilement et
notamment au niveau de la photo nuit
pour la stabilité au niveau du pétrole
prom devrait avoir un écran de 6,47
pouces oled fhd plus une résolution de
2340 par 1080 pixels
il y aurait bien évidemment un kirin 989
m 8 gigas de ram et 3 config au niveau
du stockage 128 256 ou 512 gigaoctets de
stockage on devrait avoir une très
grosse batterie de 4200 milliards
terreur de la superbe charge en usb tiff
c'est ça devrait très vite être pratique
surtout qu'il va falloir nourrir ce
grand écran qui va consommer à mon avis
ça va être vraiment une bête de compet
de ce point de vue là en terme de photos
justement qu'est-ce qu'on va avoir
et c'est là où ça devient encore plus
intéressant on devrait avoir un capteur
de 40 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 1.6 avec
une stabilisation optique ultra
performant en faible luminosité
un deuxième capteur de 20 mégapixels
grand-angle avec une ouverture de f 2.2
qui vous permettra de prendre des photos
forcément là comme le nom l'indiqué avec
un plus grand angle et là où
l'innovation va aller encore plus loin
c'est au niveau du zoom
on va voir un zoom optique x 7,8 fois
7,8 et en hybride x 10 c'est justement
ce que nous a annoncé huawei je le
regarde les petites notes j'ai tout est
noté si c'est ce qu'ils appellent le
super zoom périscopique x 10 en gros
l'idée c'est que lorsque vous avez pris
votre photo vous allez être 15 ou mme x
10 sans perte de qualité
et là je crois que ça va aller encore
plus loin
je sais pas pourquoi je saccades ma
parole quand je parle comme ça mais ça
va aller encore plus loin que ce que
proposait la concurrence en termes de
photos à mon avis ça va être assez
hallucinant vous prenez en photo un
paysage nous voulons garder qu'une
partie pouvait le faire sans perte de
qualité
ça va faire mal et en plus de ça en
aurait ici là ce petit rond c'est un
capteur tough c'est la caméra time of
light
en gros c'est un capteur en trois
dimensions qui reconnaît les objets qui
peut modéliser pas mal de choses ça vous
servira surtout pour la réalité
augmentée pour l'instant il n'y a pas
énormément design on va aller encore
plus loin c'est encore reconnaître aussi
les volumes vous dire par exemple
lorsque vous avez un muffin par exemple
dans la main calculer le volume et de là
à en déduire les calories donc ça peut
aider pour la nutrition ça peut aider
pour le jeu ça peut aider pour plein de
choses il ya plein usage d'arrière et en
tout cas ça promet vraiment d'être très
intéressant à l'avant on aurait une
caméra de 30 2 mégapixels tout ça
tournerait sur eux est venu
neuf points sur un android 9 paille
il y aura bien évidemment de
certification ip68 double carte sim du
nfc pour le paiement dématérialisé du
wifi 6 du bluetooth 5.0 enfin la
complète en imaginant smartphone hyper
complet point intéressant l'écran ne
seraient pas fabriqués par lg cette
année mais par samsung display a priori
ou huawei aurait confié l'ensemble de la
production à samsung display ce qu' ils
sont convaincus plus par la qualité des
écrans samsung display que par ceux de
l'egypte
allez savoir toujours est il que vous
prenez un smartphone ultra haut de gamme
en termes de photos voulu apposer un
écran d'une excellente qualité comme le
fait parfaitement bien samsung display
tout ça avec de l'intelligence
artificielle parce que au final on voit
qu'on va avoir trois appareils photo 4
avec la camerata move like 4 capteur à
l'arrière un capteur à l'avant donc cinq
capteurs en tout sur le pétrole pro et
tout ça avec de l'intelligence
artificielle et un traitement logiciel
complètement optimisé
on pourra faire des photos qu'on imagine
même pas aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
là où le 26 mars on va avoir une vraie
belle surprise
on va prendre probablement une petite
gifle donc je vous invite une fois de
plus à vous abonner comme ça vous sauver
vous de son côté notre ami le paie 30
qui est là et qui est là alors il
devrait avoir un écran de 6,1 pouces
oled fhd plus toujours un cri 986 j4m
cette fois ci une version 128 giga de
stockage une grosse batterie de 3650
millan terreur de la super charge bien
évidemment en usb techs et en usb type c
est au niveau de l'appareil photo
nourrit un triple capteurs 40 mégapixels
courir et à f 1.8 un grand-angle 16
mégapixels courir à f 2.2 et un 8
mégapixels avec un zoom alors le zoom je
ne saurais pas vous dire probablement un
zoom x 5,5 une ouverture de f 2.4 et à
l'avant c'est-à-dire ici vous auriez
également une caméra de 30 2 mégapixels
et il aurait la surcouche em 89.1 sur un
android 9 paille
alors bien évidemment il sera aussi typé
68 double nano cimes du wifi du
bluetooth 5.0 du nfc et dans les deux
modèles a priori il n'y aurait pas deux
prises jack avoir ça le 26 mars prochain
qui dit petite encoche goutte d'eau dit
forcément qu'il n'y a pas la place pour
installer une caméra en trois dimensions
n'ont pas de reconnaissance de visages
de scal 2010
on devrait avoir néanmoins un capteur
d'empreinte digitale intégrée à l'écran
ça serait plutôt cool j'imagine un
capteur d'empreintes digitales
ultrasonique on verra s'il va vite on
pourra comparer justement par rapport au
samsung galaxy s disent plus que j'ai en
tête depuis quelques jours donc ça je
vous dirai ce qu'il en ressort déjà le
26 mars
ce sens mais plutôt intéressant et qui
on va le tester après donc c'est pareil
on en reparlera on verra beaucoup de
points là dessus on testera la partie
photo on restera la performance enfin il
y aura vraiment beaucoup de choses à
dire sur ses nouveaux modèles de 2019
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir un peu de
ce qu'on vend tout de suite en termes de
rumeurs eh bien on voit que huawei
continue sa progression monte en
puissance même si on compte des
difficultés aux états unis huawei
continue à monter en flèche
ça c'est plutôt intéressant il ya de
belles propositions derrière de belles
propositions en termes d' usage
multimédia photos ça je voulais déjà
dissous ça vraiment vraiment
intéressante surtout ce qui est très
intéressant c'est cette grosse
compétition
sur la photo il yad'excellents
photophone le google pixels 3 avec un
seul capteur photo fait un travail
énorme d'un point de vue logiciel c'est
juste monstrueux samsung avec notamment
son galaxy s 10 plus à une très très
belle proposition très bien équilibré ça
j'en ai déjà parlé dans la vidéo test
justement du galaxy s 10 plus et la
huawei avec le pétrole et surtout avec
le p 30 pro pourrait franchement raf est
la vedette aux autres et continuer à
exploser ses ventes en 2010 neuf et ça
c'est plutôt intéressant donc je vous
invite à venir vous ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire est ce que vous
êtes satisfait de huawei est ce que vous
pensez que en 2018 déjà huawei a
vraiment explosé et va continuer sa
progression en 2019 et si vous avez des
modèles de weck est ce que vous pensez
justement de la qualité photo vidéo de
l'écran puis l'utilisation en règle
générale vous marquez tout ça bien
évidemment aux commentaires on va
reparler le 26 et quelques jours après
j'étais surprise pour l'instant je n'en
dis pas plus avec franchement cool vous
allez voir on fait un truc un petit peu
différent ça fait vraiment vraiment
intéressant je vous invite bien
évidemment à rester connectés et puis
surtout à consulter ma playlist qui doit
s'afficher par là par là sur lequel je
vous présente tous les nouveaux
smartphones du moment il ya des trucs
vraiment intéressant voilà vous en masse
pour nous envoie plein gromyko plein de
bec
où que vous soyez sur la terre en france
au canada en algérie en belgique partout
à nouméa où vous voulez vous vous
embrasse
à bientôt ciao